the most important part which is this
whole idea that they're giving you the
free money so if i give you five dollars
yeah right and i'm like yo buy that
coffee yeah and i'm gonna give you the
five dollars to do it but also when i
give you the five dollars that coffee
now cost six dollars yeah i actually
didn't help you i [__] you yeah right
because what i'm doing is the cost of
goods are going up so here's the the
biggest sham of it all is that there's
something called official numbers of the
government reports government comes out
it's like oh look inflation's this
number unemployment's this number and
then everyone basically behind closed
doors that's like in the know they're
like
but like the unofficial numbers so like
what the [__] is the unofficial
inflation number the official number is
like 1.4 but honestly
the unofficial number is like five
yeah i don't see how you keep printing
money without massive inflation so i
guess my curiosity about inflation again
i don't want to get too much into this i
want to get to crypto yeah we're like
talking about like super like serious
[__] yeah i'm going to have fun
this is good i like the fact this is
serious now my curiosity about the
inflation is my understanding about
inflation is it's not about the printing
of money you get inflation when there's
more money than there are things to buy
kind of if we're making it in it's most
simple yeah yeah and because there
wasn't that velocity of the economy
earlier the increase in money just has
to match the velocity that the i guess
the fed wants here's a simpler way to
think about it as you create more money
you devalue the thing you're creating
right so if you're scarce there's less
if something's plenty full it's worth
it's worth less uh if you take the u.s
stock market from 1971 and you
denominated in dollars it looks like a
perfect line up into the right at a 45
degree angle right there's dips along
the way whatever but it's a 45 degree
angle for decades
if you denominate the same stock market
in gold and sound money the stock market
is down since 1971.
so is it actually at the stock market's
accruing value or is that dollars being
devalued because it's a fraction right
a share versus a dollar that's a bar so
here you ready for this yes that [__]
me up dude this this is why the wealth
inequality gap gets so bad right so this
forget all bitcoin stuff the number one
thing people need to understand is
the richest people in america know one
secret and it's don't hold cash
invest hold investable assets that's all
i do is hold cash yeah it's literally
all i've been having this is all i do
for you i've been telling you oh my god
you're still much richer than me so i
don't worry about it but for years i've
been telling i want to keep it that way
that's why we have anthony yeah yeah 100
yeah you have almost one whole bitcoin
and i i literally
let me tell you something i listened to
tim ferriss's podcast immediately i was
like you know what the [__] oh gosh who
knows i don't know i was absolutely
furious and then mark reminded me he was
like yeah i think akash is all in on
bitcoin i was like it's at 60 000
whoa
actually maybe a good way into bitcoin
buy another shirt
i
can't
what do you want from me no but
literally i'm such a [__] baboon with
money i just i keep it in this in my
bank account i even tell my business
manager i was like no don't put it
anywhere yeah but but think about this
right you're financially incentivized
not to hold cash so they're de-valued
all i do is hold the cash they tell you
right the official numbers are hey we're
going to devalue it on average about two
percent a year yeah right so if you have
a hundred dollars you're losing
purchasing power every year if you hold
five years right it's worth less and so
the idea is so valuable that you have
two you have two options if you know the
dial like think of it as melting ice
cube right and you know your cash is
losing its purchasing power you can
either do one of two things you can
exchange it for goods and services you
can consume velocity of money let's
[__] roll let's make the government
happy or you can invest i don't want to
[__] just spend it and own some
[__] thing that's not going to be
worth more money in the future i want to
buy real estate stocks precious metals
bitcoin whatever so what ends up
happening is that the bottom 45 of
americans have no investable assets they
own nothing they are you you are the
bottom 45 percent of americans maybe not
net worth but in mindset right and and
education is the most insulting yeah
yeah keep going anthony so the bottom 45
percent when this happens basically the
money's being devalued literally 45 of
americans are getting poorer and poorer
over time because their net worth they
have paycheck to paycheck all their cash
in the bank it's losing value
rich people are sitting there guess what
happened when they were printing all
this money the stock market went to the
[__] moon because people like i gotta
get my money out of cash because they're
just printing liquidity everywhere guess
what else went up yeah gold bitcoin real
estate all investable assets go up
because they're devaluing the dollar and
so the other component of this that
makes it even worse is that if you're in
the bottom 40 50 of americans the goods
you consume the things you buy are super
inflationary you buy gas you buy food
you buy all this stuff right people at
the top on a percentage basis the amount
of money they spend on gas and food is
like minuscule compared to the investing
they do right if you're rich you do a
lot more investing than you do consuming
gas and food if you're not rich you
spend an inordinate amount of your
income on rent gas food etc
so guess what's been happening food
prices have gone through the [__]
roof gas prices have gone through the
roof right all this stuff so literally
the bottom half of america is being put
in a worse situation than the top half
yeah they say sorry to interrupt but
they say i think they say like poor
people
spend middle class people save rich
people invest that's a great way
but it would seem the middle class
people as the dollar loses more and more
value like you said it's a melting ice
cube so their savings is worth less and
less and that's how the wealth gap so
the most egregious example of this is in
countries where there's hyperinflation
right we don't have hyperinflation in
america i don't think hyperinflation is
coming anytime soon right but if you
look at a hyperinflationary uh
environment let's say like venezuela
zimbabwe et cetera you could literally
start the day off and you're like you
don't want that that cup of coffee it
costs the equivalent of five dollars and
by night time it costs ten dollars
and you're just like yo you're just
watching this [__] fall like literally
they're changing the prices as it goes i
have in my wallet right now yeah uh i
think it's a 50 million dollar boliviar
uh
yeah you know bill and i think it's a
hundred trillion or one trillion dollar
zimbabwe bill
wow like they used to not have that now
they have that why because literally the
dollar got devalued those currencies got
devalued so much that they literally had
to create bigger and bigger
denominations yeah so you can actually
carry it around you've heard the stories
about this like uh i think in the south
during the civil war they they created
uh the south created their own current
currency and then people were like wheel
barreling them down to the store to get
of course yeah okay